[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima here
bringing you everything you need to know
from episode 2 of season 21 of The
Bachelor it started out with a bang
yes the slap we had seen in a teaser
turned out to be just part of a group
date which we guessed it did look like a
little bit of acting there Nick took the
ladies to the Museum of broken
relationships and of course a few
relationships got broken on this episode
Liz's secret was revealed it came out
that yes she and Nick had slept together
before the season ever begun and Nick
sent Liz home I just don't think we have
a future and his thing is best for both
of us um if I say goodbye tonight that
actually echoes a sentiment that he gave
et before this season ever began how
would you react if any of your your past
women came back for cameos or anything
else um that would be interesting as far
as my relationships whether it's been on
TV or not my past is my past and while
I've hadn't been very fortunate meet
some great women for me I feel like
those ships have sailed and Corinne
continues to make a name for herself in
many ways the ladies also took on the
task of a photoshoot in which they all
posed as brides and here's how Corinne
really made her mark okay
oh well she walked away with a rose so
what do you guys think is nick's
connection with Corinne for real let me
know over on Twitter
[Music]
you